-For the past eight days
in cities across the country,
Americans have protested the
recent murder of George Floyd
at the hands of police.
Many of those protests
have turned violent,
due not to the protesters,
but to the response
of the police themselves.
Here to comment on that
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, with a segment
called "Amber's Minute of Fury."
♪♪
-Fool!
Dang police violence
at these protests!
What are you doing?!
Your response to "please stop
unnecessarily hurting us"
is to go to a peaceful protest
and unnecessarily hurt us?
Your response to
"we think you are too violent"
is this outfit?
You idiots! "Stop killing
Black people" is so easy.
It's like when they give you
a point on the SATs
for just writing your name.
But it's clear
some police can't handle that,
so maybe there's an adult
in the room who can go, "Okay.
Now, no more killing
Black people. And I mean it."
And then everyone else can just
be like, "Yeah, you're right."
Is that possible?
Oh, wait, wait. The President
is going to talk soon.
He'll save us.
-I am mobilizing all available
federal resources,
civilian and military, to stop
the rioting and looting.
-Damn! That --
That doesn't help at all!
This is crazy!
At least this is
the only emergency
facing our nation at the moment.
Coronavirus?!
No one took care of coronavirus?
Whose job was it? No one's?
Wow! This is the craziest April
I've ever been a part of.
June?!
Okay, so, the officer arrested
for killing George Floyd,
Derek Chauvin, had 18 previous
complaints filed against him.
Eighteen?
How is he still policing?
If you stick your hand
in the pudding
at The Golden Corral once,
you will never be allowed
back in there -- so I heard.
Being a cop is easier than
eating at The Golden Corral?!
I'm just kidding.
I've never acted crazy in public
or anything like that,
because when Black people
do that,
we run the risk
of being murdered.
[ Ding! ]
Now, I know
what you're thinking --
"Not all cops are bad.
I heard some of them are
kneeling with the protesters."
So, look, I don't like to get
mad at people for trying.
I don't think that's very nice.
I can see how, on the surface,
police kneeling
alongside the protesters
is a nice gesture,
but, um, how do I say this?
Uh, get up off the ground
and help us!
Train your little friends
to do their job correctly!
Make it illegal
to kill us without cause
and then -- and this is where
I think you can really help --
enforce that law!
Even if it's your buddy
who breaks it!
Now, those are my suggestions,
and they're good ones.
You know what's not
a good suggestion?
Damn it, Joe!
You are not helping!
I am so sick of you already.
Just keep your mouth shut
until November
and don't say anything racist.
-If you have a problem
figuring out
whether you're for me or Trump,
then you ain't Black.
-Dang it, Joe! I swear to God.
If you don't just shut up
and let us vote for you...
Now, the protests this week have
been rough on the protesters,
but you know who else
they've been rough on?
Reporters.
These people have been arrested.
They've had rubber bullets
shot at them.
This one lady
even got shot on the air.
-We've got plenty of time here.
-Aah! Aah!
-Are you okay?
-I'm getting shot!
I'm getting --
-Kate? Katie, are you okay?
-Rubber bullets! Rubber bullets!
-And they were shot!
But I'm like, "Don't you know
why everyone is protesting?"
'Cause the police like
to hurt people for no reason.
This is like
going to a bake sale
and being surprised
when you see muffins.
"M-M-Muffins
at a ba-ba-bake sale?!"
Yeah, dummy!
Now, I can remember years ago
when everyone was talking
about stop and frisk.
And I swear to God, I was like,
"It's illegal for cops
to do us like that?"
I'm telling you,
I had experienced it and seen it
so many times,
it never occurred to me
that that might not be allowed.
So, yeah, the police
might hurt you without cause.
Oh, my God. I almost forgot.
Okay, there was one reporter
who got cuffed
and taken away on air --
and before you ask,
of course, he was --
but then he was
back to reporting
after the commercial break!
Do you know how much resilience
that takes?
Once there was
a spider on my desk,
and I went home for the day.
Oh, hold on. I just heard the
President is going to talk.
He'll save us.
-One law and order.
And that is what it is.
One law.
We have one beautiful law.
-That wasn't helpful at all!
Damn!
Meanwhile,
in the middle of all this,
these two idiots
just [bleep] left us here.
Cowardly spacemen!
They got to leave the planet.
I can't even leave my house
because of
coronavirus AND curfew.
But that's okay because
the President is on TV again,
and I bet he's going to do
something really helpful.
[ Sirens wailing ]
-Why?! What are you doing?!
You know what? I don't think
he's gonna help us.
And we are in a dangerous spot
because this fool
is amping up the rhetoric.
This is a real problem.
And for things to change,
we need real leaders.
Leaders who have the courage
to take a stand for our safety.
-I won't traffic
in fear and division.
I won't fan the flames of hate.
I'll seek to heal
the racial wounds
that have long plagued
our country,
not use them for political gain.
I'll do my job,
and I will take responsibility.
I won't blame others.
-Thank you, Joe. Good job.
Now back in the basement
until November!
This has been
"Amber's Minute of Fury."
♪♪
-Thank you, Amber Ruffin.
We'll be right back
with Amanda Peet.